hey everybody welcome to this next
episode of your daily equation today I'm
going to focus upon the relativistic
mass equation the relativistic mass
formula some people love this equation
some people despise it I'll describe why
that is but let me let me just give you
a quick sense of why I think it's
important for us to cover many people
ask me why is it that the speed of light
is the maximum possible speed why is it
a barrier and the relativistic mass
formula at least gives you some
intuition for an answer to that
important question it gives you some
understanding of why it is that if you
try to push an object and speed it up to
the speed of light you will always fail
you can get close to the speed of light
but you can't actually reach the speed
of item certainly you can't exceed the
speed of light okay so what is the
relativistic mass formula we begin by
even just writing it down for you and
then we'll explain it so it says that
the relativistic mass is equal to the
mass of an object with a little zero on
the bottom that means the mass of the
object at rest this is called the rest
mass and there's an additional factor
which is one over the square root of one
minus the velocity squared of the object
divided by C squared and for those of
you who have been following along in
previous discussions you will know that
this is the gamma factor that crops up
all over the place and the special
theory of relativity and the key part of
this equation is that you see that the
relativistic mass depends on V on the
speed of an object so the first thing
that I want to do is try to give you
some understanding of why in the world
you'd ever suspect that there's a useful
notion of mass or heft that depends
not just on the stuff that makes up the
object but also the speed from any given
perspective that that stuff is executing
why would speed come into the story and
to to give you a little intuition for
that I'm gonna tell you a brief little
story that I think helps you gain that
rough understanding that intuition for
speed affecting heft and here's the
story
I call it the parable of the two
chapters so cast your mind back to
medieval times and imagine that there
are two opponents in a stadium that are
engaged in a joust but I'm going to
modify the joust from probably the image
you have in mind in two important ways
number one the Lance that each of these
two opponents carries doesn't have a
sharp blade at the top rather it has a
metallic sphere at the top second change
rather than taking their metallic
spheres and trying to like knock the
opponent in the head or in the body to
try to knock them off their horse in
this particular version of the jaws what
the opponents do is they slam their
spheres together as they pass and in
that way try to knock the other one off
the horse okay so let me show you an
animation of this and in this animation
before I show it they're going to be two
opponents that I call Brian
and evil Brian they kind of look like me
a little bit and the stipulation and it
will be clear why I'm saying this and
the outcome of the joust is that Brian
and evil Brian are completely equally
matched in every way so when they engage
in this jaws they go toward each other
on the horses they thrust their
respective Lance's at each other and
because they're equally matched
neither falls off the horse it's a draw
it's a tie okay now all I want to do is
a simple change of perspective and that
animation we were looking at the joust
say from
the standpoint of somebody in the
bleachers looking down at the
competition now I want you and me to
take my perspective in this competition
and view the unfolding from my
perspective now from my perspective I am
an observer moving at fixed beat in a
fixed direction so I can claim to be at
rest so from my view I'm just sort of
sitting there as evil Brian is coming
toward me now imagine that the horses
involved are like really fast horses
relativistic horses so their speed is
like really large it means the effects
of relativity are more pronounced right
now from my perspective if I if I
carefully think through what happens to
evil Brian if I if I observe what
happens and then really fun look through
my understanding of the special theory
of relativity that we've already
discussed
I recognize that because evil Brian is
in motion
evil Brian's watch must be ticking off
time slower than my watch and look when
we talk about that effect that time
dilation effect bear in mind that we're
not like referring to some weird
physicists abstract notion of time I'm
really referring to time itself the rate
at which processes unfold so when evil
Brian is experiencing this time dilation
from my perspective that applies to
everything all of evil brian's motions
slow down right the blinking of the eyes
are slow the turning around is all slow
and in particular I conclude from that
thinking through the situation that evil
brian's thrust of the Lance is going to
be really slow too and so naively at
first blush I come to the conclusion
that this is going to be an easy victory
and easy win a piece of cake
because evil Brian is thrusting the
Lance at me in slow motion but in
reality of course we know that it can't
be a victor
for me because we already saw from the
perspective of the bleachers that it is
a draw so indeed if we now look at this
situation evil Brian thrust slowly I
thrust it quickly but it is still a
drawn out first I'm a little confused by
the fact that I didn't win but then I
think things through a little bit more
carefully and I realized that the that
the impact that the thrust that I
experienced the force that I experienced
from evil Brian actually depends not on
one but on two things right one of those
things is indeed the speed of the thrust
so we've got actually two two speeds in
this story you've got the speed of evil
Brian's horse you've got the speed of
the thrust so to distinguish them I'll
call it the speed of the thrust I'll
just write it underneath there so the
speed of the thrust from my perspective
is indeed decreased by a factor of gamma
I'm actually put a gamma of V in there
with that V and let me just give some
colors here is this V right here that's
the V of the horse okay the the speed of
evil Brian approaching me from from my
perspective so the speed of the thrust
is decreased by this factor of gamma but
I realized that there's an additional
factor that affects the impact and that
factor is of course the mass of the
object that is hitting me right I mean
we all know this in everyday life if if
a mosquito slams into you even at high
speed are you afraid of that I don't
think so right because even if it's
relatively high speed I'm not talking
relativistic speeds here but even if
it's relatively high speed the mass of
the mosquito is so minuscule that the
impact is tiny but if if a Mack truck is
slamming into you even if it has low
speed even if it's going slowly because
the Mack truck has such a huge mass that
can really cause significant
so it's the product of these two factors
not just the speed but also the mass
comes into that effect and therefore if
I want to explain how it is that I
didn't win in this competition I said in
myself look it is the case that evil
Brian is thrusting that Lance at me in
slow motion but it must be the case that
the mass of evil Brian's sphere must
compensate for that slowdown of the
thrust
how would it compensate well if it picks
up a factor of gamma of V then the gamma
of the upstairs and the gamma of V
downstairs oh sorry about that little
ringing of the telephone that happens on
occasion here but let's just ignore it
and keep on going the gamma that we get
from the slowdown in the thrust and the
gamma that we get Oh be quiet telephone
already over there all right I'm gonna
have to answer this phone if I find it
well just gonna let it go
so the the slowdown in the thrust ah it
stopped ringing thank God
so the slowdown of the thrust is
compensated for by an increase in the
mass and there you have basically our
formula if I just scroll down over here
relativistic mass is the mass at rest
and that's really what I mean by this
term over here multiplied by the factor
of gamma so this little parable of the
jousters at least gives you some sense
of where we would be led to think about
a mass that would be velocity dependent
that would increase as a factor of the
velocity and when we now write this out
in a little bit more detail and analyze
it we see that it yields this wonderful
intuition as to why the speed of light
is a speed limit so if you're right
and relativistic is M naught times 1
over the square root of 1 minus V
squared over C squared and ask ourselves
what happens to the relativistic mass as
V approaches C well it gets larger and
larger in fact let me show you that
bring up this little graph here and
notice that when the speed is small the
relativistic mass hardly differs from
the rest mass but as the approaches the
speed of light the curve zips up goes
arbitrarily large zips up toward
infinity and that's a very useful
realization because if you have an
object whatever even if it's a ping-pong
ball and you're trying to speed it up
ever more quickly you apply a force but
if the mass of the ping-pong ball gets
ever bigger as its speed gets ever
larger then you have to give an even
larger force to speed it up further
still and as the ping-pong ball or any
object approaches the speed of light its
heft its relativistic mass source toward
infinity which means you'd need an
infinite push tipica to get it to go
faster still there's no such thing as an
infinite push and that's why you can get
close to the speed of light but you
can't push an object up to the speed of
light that's why the speed of light is
indeed a limiting speed for any material
object final point that I want to make
before I'm done is that when you think
about Einsteins e equals mc-squared you
should now ask yourself which M is it in
e equals mc-squared right is it the
relativistic mass or is it the rest mass
and the answer is it's actually the
relativistic mass because when we talk
about energy on the left-hand side we're
talking about the total energy right the
energy from motion has to be included in
that expression and you only include it
if you have a V on the right-hand side
and indeed therefore the real way of
writing Einstein's famous equation is e
equals M not 1 over the square root of 1
minus V squared over C squared
see squared now I trust you will agree
that saying equals M not 1 over the
square root of 1 minus V squared over C
squared times C squared does not have
the same ring as e equals mc-squared and
that then motivates you to introduce the
definition that we started with call
this the relativistic mass and then you
can write equals M relativistic and that
should be a an L not a V there and
relativistic times C squared and that's
the the full version of Einstein's e
equals mc-squared and it's also useful
to write this in one other equivalent
way making use of what's known as a
Maclaurin series or a Taylor series
expansion which is valid for those of
you who are familiar with this little
additional detail when V over C is a
good deal less than 1 and V is a good
deal less than C you can do if you know
a little bit of calculus an expansion of
that 1 over the square root of 1 minus V
squared over C squared in powers of V
over C squared and if you do that and
maybe at some point I don't know how
long we're gonna go on with the series
but if we do some calculus and some
expansions I like to show you how this
goes but for the time being let me just
write down the answer that you get if
you expand the 1 over square root of 1
minus V squared over C squared and
multiply it by the M naught C squared
what you get well you will get M naught
C squared plus 1/2 M naught times V
squared plus 3/8 times M naught V to the
fourth over C squared and I think the
next term if I'm doing this in my head
which is always dangerous who do correct
me if I'm wrong on this I think it would
be 5/16 V to the 6 over C to the fourth
and blah blah blah dot dot now this is a
kind of wonderful little expression here
because one of these terms is familiar
to anybody who took high school physics
which I hope is all of you this is just
ordinary kinetic and
gee that you learned from Isaac Newton
in your course on classical physics this
term over here is the new term that
Einstein gives us and it tells us that
the total energy of an object actually
is non zero even when the object is at
rest
right this term does not have a V in it
and it says and that's why we call it
frozen energy not the best terminology
but it's energy that the particle has
even when it's not moving when it's
sitting still and that's its rest mass
times C squared and then you have all
this other stuff which are relativistic
Corrections that Newton didn't know
about that emerge from this more
complete understanding so it's a nice
formula that brings together Newtonian
physics
einsteinium physics relativistic physics
in one complete package okay so that's
all I had to say today about the
relativistic mass formula and we'll
carry on next time but for today that is
your daily equation looking forward to
seeing you next time until then take
care